plaisir de pouvoir en prendre à ces
familles je pensais qu'on allait pas
pouvoir le faire
c'est souvent l'impression que les rôles
nous choisissent plus qu'on ne les
choisit quand j'ai commencé le tournage
d'un fils qui parle de la filiation
je venais juste de raccompagner mon père
sur sa terre l'issue sera sur sa terre
natale pardon sur laquelle il repose d
dans laquelle il repose désormais on a
tourné le film dans le désert de
tataouine à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière libyenne où dans les années 40
mon père alors âgé d'une dizaine
d'années traversé clandestinement cette
même frontière avec son père pour
rejoindre le village natal de mon grand
père que je n'ai jamais connu toute sa
vie il m'a raconté ce pays ce périple
jusqu'à la fin ça revenait il me
racontait le désert les passeurs la
fatigue et surtout la stupeur de se
réveiller un matin sans son père qui
pour aller plus vite et craignant les
rafles l'avait laissée aux bons soins
d'un passeur jusqu'à son retour en y
repensant aujourd'hui j'ai le sentiment
que tout ceci ma et le personnage
s'est invitée en moi il m'a inspiré son
désarroi ces regards son amour je les
habite et je vais donner mon souffle en
énergie
mehdi barsaoui le metteur en scène
neiges la benabdallah ma partenaire ont
fait le reste avec eux je partage ce
prix et je voudrais citer rapidement le
les producteurs et les distributeurs qui
sont vraiment des sd des aventuriers des
temps modernes et sans qui ce ce film et
tant d'autres films comme cela n'aurait
pas eu lieu
n'aurait pas eu n'aurait pas vu le jour
pardon c'est l'émotion sincèrement habib
attia chantal fischer mark herr maire et
s'arrache à celles et tous les gens de
jour de fête qui se retrouvent reconnect
rang derrière eux et merci à tous merci
[Applaudissements]